yeah so it was just a dope time like
above everything
in here boy like because regardless of
like the mistakes that
we all make just growing in this game
this game is a very
dark and slithery game if you get in the
wrong shade and once you get to a
certain height
meaning and when you say that i can go
into context because people always say
that so to the kids that's
watching the [ __ ] it's just about
intention everybody that's in this game
isn't in it for the right reason
you know what i'm saying so because you
got good we rolled up as well or
something
um but everybody's not in it for the
right reason so
you got some people who's dark and want
to cheat you out of deals or divide
homies up so that they can get closer to
this person that looks like the biggest
producer so they can have all to say so
so they can be the one to have the
30 or whatever it gets slithery so
above everything we maintain the
brotherhood like we maintain like we
never get out here and get to smutting
each other and doing the wild nutty [ __ ]
nobody ever really truly cheated nobody
like him ain't never cheat us
like he just didn't know the game you
know what i mean and that's just it is
what it is like
everybody ain't like everybody's not
just
ultimate business everybody's not barry
gordy because they're [ __ ] just
super musically talented you can't
expect that all the time you know
no for sure do you think uh like as
as a homie like how dope is it to see
like the year that he's having man
because man it's historical i could man
cry i probably i don't know if i have or
not you know i mean that's my real
brother we didn't cry
in the studio before we really had
moments so like me
like seeing his son you know what i'm
saying just seeing what he didn't been
through like he wouldn't been through
some wild [ __ ] behind closed doors
that's that happened
within these years that's also charged
him up it's also made him
treat look at [ __ ] different you know
he didn't really went through some wild
[ __ ] you feel me so
i'm just like so proud and just so
inspired you know that's always been my
big homie you know what i'm saying i
just said like
when i was first making beats that [ __ ]
was laying on his bed [ __ ]
with his laptop on his chest like not
even paying me no mind cause my beats
were so weak
and i was just going through like weird
ass sounds and he just was like
i actually had a dope beat but i had a
weak ass sound in here he just was like
sound selection is key little homie
that's what he literally looked over and
told me that night never forgot that
[ __ ]
i think about it every time i create
music are you are you still producing
hell yeah man how much how much of the
album did you produce
um i did like two or three beats i did
maya though
featuring dope yeah and um i did
uh watermelon with tony stiff
so i did like two or three and then on
my new [ __ ] i got a lot of
[ __ ]